[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich Willkommen zu 20
Minuten Nachrichten und die
argentinischen Fußballweltmeister ziehen
gerade durch Buenos Aires Norbert
Meister aus Frankreich haben sich
gestern Abend in Paris dann doch noch
richtig feiern lassen und unterm auf
diese Themen schauen wir auch
fehlende Medikamente für Kinder
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach wird
Preisvorschriften lockern um Lücken zu
füllen
China meldet erstmals wieder corona-tote
will aber trotz voller Krankenhäuser und
Infektionswelle an der Öffnung
festhalten
und Chaos auf dem Weg in die Feiertage
am Flughafen Frankfurt fehlen die
Mitarbeiter viel Zeit und gute Nerven
sind gefragt
wer zur Zeit in einer Apotheke nach
Fiebersaft für Kinder fragt hat es
vielleicht schon selber erlebt erst
schwer zu bekommen es gibt Engpässe bei
einigen Medikamenten
Bundesgesundheitsminister Lauterbach
will daher kurz gesagt dass die
Pharmaindustrie künftig für bestimmte
Medikamente mehr Geld erhält die
Einzelheiten von Winnie hescher
hustenfieber sorgen Familie texera hat
sich aufgemacht in die Niederlande dort
sind Medikamente zwar teurer aber es
gibt sie anders als in manch deutscher
Apotheker derzeit wenn man so eine
hochfiebernes Kind hatte man bekommt
dann nichts es ist absolut nicht
nachvollziehbar der Gesundheitsminister
ist unter Druck das zu ändern mit
finanziellen Anreizen für die
Pharmaindustrie
die
Regelung für Kinder geht dahin geht
sofort dass ich die Krankenkassen heute
angeschrieben habe und darum gebeten
habe dass tatsächlich dieser erhöhte
Preis 50 Prozent mehr dass diese erhöhte
Preis auch sofort bezahlt werden kann
und bezahlt werden sollte somit ist das
eine Regelung wo ich unmittelbarer
Wirkung erwartet 50 Prozent mehr damit
sich für Hersteller der Verkauf in
Deutschland mehr lohnt außerdem sollen
Apotheken Fieber und Hustensäfte selbst
herstellen und abrechnen dürfen die aber
rechnen nicht wie Lauterbach mit
kurzfristiger Besserung das Problem sei
hausgemacht es geht immer nur darum dass
der billigste letztendlich seine
Medikamente verkaufen kann und dies
System hat dazu geführt dass eben in
Deutschland und Europa nichts mehr
produziert werden kann weil der
Preisdruck für die Pharmaindustrie
einfach zu groß ist auch die
Krankenkassen reagieren kritisch sie
sprechen von einem Weihnachtsgeschenk
für die Pharmaindustrie
man kann aber nicht davon ausgehen dass
eine solche Preiserhöhung jetzt die
Produktion antreibt weil das ist etwas
was natürlich gar nicht kurzfristig geht
deswegen kann sich jeder vorstellen dass
die Industrie gerne dieses Geld mitnimmt
ohne dass ich an der aktuellen Situation
für die Kinder irgendetwas ändert das
werden Eltern in den nächsten Tagen
selbst prüfen können ob Sie die
gewünschten Medikamente bekommen oder
nicht für ihre kranken Kinder
seit genau 300 Tagen tobt der russische
Angriffskrieg in der Ukraine Präsident
selenski besuchte heute überraschend die
seit Wochen heftig umkämpfte und
belagerte Stadt bachmut dort sprach er
mit militärvertretern und zeichnete
Soldaten mit Orden aus
silensky hatte bachmut zuvor als den
gefährlichsten Ort auf der mehr als
1.300 Kilometer lange Frontlinie
bezeichnet
und in der Ukraine ist unsere reporterin
Anne Brühl Anne 300 Tage Krieg wie ist
da der Besuch von silenzkennerfront zu
bewerten
das ist schon ein Ausrufezeichen dass
der Präsident mit diesem Besuchern
diesem Ort heute gesetzt hat denn
bachmut dafür führen ja Russen und
Ukrainer seit Monaten an blutigen und
verlustreichen Stellungskrieg und
selensky hat heute die Zahl von 99.000
getöteten russischen Soldaten in diesem
Krieg genannt von den eigenen
ukrainischen Verlusten hat er nicht
gesprochen und auch die sind sehr hoch
im Kampf um bachmut dieser Besuch an der
Fronter fällt nicht so ungefähr in einer
Zeit in der die eigentlichen
Kriegshandlung fast so ein bisschen
eingefroren wirken auf der anderen Seite
aber die ukrainische Zivilbevölkerung
natürlich massiv unter diesen heftigen
Angriffswellen auf die Infrastruktur
hier im landet und trotz allem wenn wir
mit den Menschen hier auf der Straße
sprechen dann hören wir da immer eine
sehr große Entschiedenheit die Ukraine
wird siegen wird uns immer wieder gesagt
und diese Zuversicht die hatte selenski
mit seinem Besuch in bachmut heute
sicherlich noch einmal
Kontakt Dankeschön für diese Einordnung
aus der Ukraine
bundesverteidigungsministerin Lambrecht
hat zum Abschluss ihrer slowakei-reise
eine Bundeswehreinheit besucht die 250
Soldatinnen und Soldaten gehören zu
einer nato-kampftruppe die nach dem
russischen einmarschen die Ukraine in
das Slowakei aufgestellt worden waren
Lambrecht sagte dem Land zu weitere
luftverteidigungssysteme zu liefern
stationiert sind dort bereits zwei
deutsche Patriot flugabwehrstaffeln
es ist möglicherweise der letzte sicher
aber einer der letzten Prozesse zur
Verfügung der nationalsozialistischen
Verbrechen eine ehemalige Sekretärin des
ns-konzentrationslager Struthof wurde
jetzt zu zwei Jahren auf Bewährung
verurteilt sie ist der Beihilfe zum Mord
an über 10.000 Menschen schuldig über
das Urteil des Landgericht Itzehoe
schuldig wegen Beihilfe zum Mord an mehr
als 10.000 Menschen die Sekretärin der
Mörder
heute 77 Jahre nach Kriegsende ist sie
für ihre Taten verurteilt worden als
Sekretärin im KZ stutuf hat sie unter
anderem die Listen mit den Namen der
Ermordeten abgetippt damals war Irmgard
furchtner gerade mal 18 19 Jahre alt
deshalb verurteilte sie heute diese
Jugendkammer des Landgerichts Itzehoe
wieso jetzt fragen viele
erst jetzt durch eine Änderung der
Rechtsprechung vor wenigen Jahren ist es
möglich auch sogenannte kleine Rädchen
im großen Betrieb des massenmordens vor
Gericht zu stellen und genau deshalb ist
dieses Urteil von heute von so immenser
Bedeutung weil es auch zeigt was die
deutsche Justiz über Jahrzehnte versäumt
hat Täter Helfer Helfershelfer vor
Gericht zu stellen und es zeigt dass
jeder der einen Beitrag geleistet hat
für das Massenmorden auch verantwortlich
ist
er ist im Prozess als Zeuge aufgetreten
Josef salomonovic Überlebender sein
Vater wurde im kz-stutthof ermordet im
Gericht sprach er die Angeklagte direkt
an
ich habe ja das Bild von meinem
ermordeten Vater gezeigt
und ich habe gesagt ich wünsche mir nur
dass sie so schlecht schlafen kann so
wie ich davon
Irmgard Furchner kommt auch da keine
Reaktion keine Reue nur unverbindliche
Worte des Bedauerns am letzten
Verhandlungstag
josef salomonovic hat diese
Konfrontation mit der Vergangenheit
seine Zeugenaussage im Gericht viel
Kraft gekostet aber er sagt für ihn sei
es so wichtig weil es auch ein Verfahren
gegen das Vergessen ist
es ist eine Reise die zeigen soll wie
Ernstes Deutschland mit der Aufarbeitung
seiner kolonialverbrechen meint
bundesaußenministerin bärburg ist nach
Nigeria geflogen um die ersten kostbaren
Benin Bronson zurückzugeben die vor 125
Jahren gestohlen wurden mehr als 1100
geraubte Kunstobjekte aus dem frühen
Königreich Benehmen das heute Nigeria
liegt wurden von deutschen Museen
aufgekauft jetzt sollen die meisten nach
und nach zurückgegeben werden ein Teil
kann als Leihgabe in Deutschland bleiben
Andrea Maurer berichtet
die deutsche Außenministerin gibt ihnen
Nigerias Hauptstadt etwas zurück das
Deutschland nie gehört hat und doch über
ein Jahrhundert in seinem Besitz war 20
von über 1.100 Benin Branchen aus
deutschen Beständen einen Anfang es war
falsch diese Bronzen zu stehlen es war
falsch diese Bronzen zu behalten und es
ist mehr als überfällig dass diese
Bronzen in ihrer Heimat zurückkommen
auch die kulturstaatsministerin ist mit
nach Nigeria gekommen unter hohen
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen die Gefahr von
islamistischen Anschlägen ist
allgegenwärtig rot reist in den Süden
des Landes Benin City Hauptstadt des
früheren Königreichs Benin
1897 vielen britische Truppen hier ein
plünderten die Kunstschätze verkauften
sie an Museen in ganz Europa wer nicht
nach Europa reisen konnte hat die
Branchen die seit dem 16 Jahrhundert den
Königspalast schmückten nie gesehen bis
heute gießen Sie hier Nachbildungen der
verlorenen Kunstschätze zur Zeit meines
ururgroßvaters wurden die Branchen
gestohlen ich habe das bronzegießen von
meinem Großvater gelernt ich werde sehr
glücklich sein die echten Bronzen
endlich zu sehen
bis die Menschen die Bronzen sehen
können wird es wohl dauern dort wo das
öffentliche Museum stehen soll dass
Deutschland mit finanziert bisher nur
bauliche Deutschland gibt die Branchen
dem Staaten Nigeria zurück aber auch die
Nachfahren der Königsfamilie erheben
Ansprüche bei aller Euphorie klären die
Bronzen nun auch Heim in ein Land voller
Konflikte Korruption ungeklärte
Eigentumsrechte und ein massives
Sicherheitsproblem das ist während der
gesamten Reise offensichtlich
was mit den Benin Branchen in Nigeria
passiert darauf hat Deutschland keinen
Einfluss mehr die Branchen gehören
Deutschland nicht mehr rechtmäßig gehört
aber hat die Raubkunst Deutschland ohne
hin nie
sie wird der Korruption beschuldigt
jetzt hat die verhaftete Vizepräsidentin
des Europaparlaments er war Kylie
offenbar ein Teil Geständnis abgelegt
sie habe zugegeben ihren Vater vor der
Festnahme angewiesen zu haben Bargeld zu
verstecken so Medienberichte unter
Berufung auf ermittlungsdokumente im
Raum steht das Kata mit Geld und
Sachgeschenken versucht haben soll
politische Entscheidungen zu
beeinflussen
in China steigen die coronazahlen weiter
massiv an Krankenhäuser sind überfüllt
es fehlt an Medikamenten wie kommt das
mit Beginn der Pandemie verfolgte China
eine nullcovit-politik ganze Städte im
Lockdown die Bevölkerung streng
überwacht aber dann gab es vor wenigen
Wochen Proteste gegen die
Einschränkungen die aufgeschreckte
Staatsführung lockerte quasi über Nacht
die corona-regeln und jetzt trifft das
Virus auf ein schlecht vorbereitetes
Land mirror
wie viele in Peking gerade Corona haben
lässt sich eher an der Höhe der
paketstapel ablesen als an offiziellen
Zahlen die Lieferdienste haben noch mehr
zu tun als sonst und es fehlen Kuriere
die selbst erkrankt sind Medikamente
gegen Fieber sind genauso ausverkauft
wie Selbsttests
es ist schon belastend dass die Regeln
plötzlich gelockert wurden ohne dass die
Versorgung mit Medikamenten ausreichend
vorbereitet war aber ich bin für die
Lockerungen
es ist die Hoffnung dass es mit den
strengen corona-regeln nun vorbei ist
und das Leben wieder losgeht
die chineslich und ohne Vorbereitung die
Infektionszahlen hier schnell in die
Höhe laut offizieller Statistik gibt es
seit den Lockerungen gerade einmal
sieben Corona Todesfälle in Wirklichkeit
dürften es deutlich mehr sein vor allem
wegen der geringen Impfquote gerade bei
den älteren
vor den Krematorien der Stadt ist
deutlich mehr los in manchen
Krankenhäusern soll es so viele Tote
geben dass sie auf dem Boden aufgereiht
werden zu 100% verifizieren können wir
diese Bilder nicht
das Staatsfernsehen spielt die Folgen
der unvorbereiteten Lockerung herunter
spricht von einer Corona Erkältung und
feiert die Impfkampagne
wegen Überfüllung gibt es einige
Infusionen im Moment vor der Klinik um
Krankenhäuser zu entlasten werden
Teststationen umfunktioniert hier gibt's
zum Beispiel traditionelle chinesische
Medizin
Online-Unterricht und Schulen als
behelfskliniken drei Jahre Pandemie hat
China nicht zur Vorbereitung genutzt und
nun vor dem Coronavirus kapituliert
wann verfällt nicht genommener Urlaub
weil das bisher umstritten war hat das
Bundesarbeitsgericht das heute
grundsätzlich festgelegt wenn
Arbeitgeber ihre Beschäftigten nicht
ausdrücklich auf den Urlaubsanspruch und
Verjährungsfristen Hinweisen dann
verfallen Resturlaubstage nicht auch
nicht nach drei Jahren damit hat das
Gericht die Position der Beschäftigten
in dieser Frage gestärkt und wer sein
Resturlaub auf das Jahresende gelegt hat
dem droht der feiertagsstau auf den
Straßen sowieso bei der Bahn kann der
Personalmangel für Probleme sorgen und
fliegen ist erst recht keine Garantie
dafür dass alles glatt geht das zeigt
sich auch auf dem Flughafen in Frankfurt
am Main Susanna Santina war dort
wer in diesen Tagen in Frankfurt
abfliegt oder hier ankommt braucht viel
Geduld gestern lag es auch am Wetter das
rund 300 Flüge annulliert wurden doch
auch in den vergangenen Tagen drohten
den Passagieren Stornierungen
Verspätungen und andere Probleme
zwei Stunden im Flugzeug gesessen haben
weil wir nicht loskunden weil die Koffer
nicht rein konnten es gab keinen
Personal die haben es nicht am Geld
sitzen lassen haben uns ins Flugzeug
gefärcht und haben dann geguckt was
läuft
diese Handyaufnahmen zeigen wie es am
Wochenende am Frankfurter Flughafen
aussah
Frust war bei vielen angesagt
fehlendes Personal für doch gestern dazu
dass das Gepäck vieler Passagiere auf
sich warten ließ eineinhalb Stunden war
völlig normal
wenn wir das an dem größten deutschen
Flughafen nicht hinbekommen grundlegende
Dinge zu organisieren viel mehr an die
jegliches Verständnis wir mussten eine
Stunde im Flieger warten auf unser
Gepäck warten wir jetzt auch schon
eineinhalb Stunden keine Ahnung warum
konfrontiert mit dem Chaos am Flughafen
verweist Fraport auf unsere Anfrage hin
auf über 20% Krankenstand das verschärfe
den Personalmangel die Gewerkschaft
sieht das Hauptproblem in schlechter
Bezahlung und hatten Arbeitsbedingungen
einfach nur auslagern Bereiche weil es
kostengünstiger ist und im GmbH zu
stecken und und weitere GmbHs mit
reinzunehmen das ist in erster Linie
tariflucht auf der anderen Seite leidet
die Qualität darunter wer in diesen
Tagen über den Flughafen Frankfurt
verreisen will sollte auf jeden Fall
viel Zeit einplanen
und ein Ausnahmezustand der ganz anderen
Art erlebt Argentinien seit Sonntagabend
seit dem Gewinn der
Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft gestern nach
traf das Team um Lionel Messi in Buenos
Aires ein und wurde bei seiner Fahrt im
offenen Bus frenetisch bejubelt den
heutigen Dienstag rief der Präsident
kurzerhand zum Nationalfeiertag aus
damit das ganze Land den offiziellen
Empfang in der Hauptstadt verfolgen kann
und bei der Parade mit dabei ist für uns
Christoph rückerath Christoph ganz
Buenos Aires ist jetzt also aus dem
Häuschen
ja das kann man wirklich wörtlich nehmen
es sind 4 Millionen Menschen hier auf
der Straße in Buenos Aires sind die
aktuellen Zahlen und das sind mehr
Menschen als Buenos Aires tatsächlich
Einwohner hat es ist eine eine Feier die
wir so glaube ich hier noch nie erlebt
haben es sind die ganze Nacht über
Menschen aus dem ganzen Land hier
hingefahren seit gestern Abend wird rund
um den oberlisten die man etwas weiter
weg hinter mir hier sehen kann hier
können wir nicht gerade weil das Handy
nicht ganz zusammenbricht seit gestern
Abend wird dort gefeiert gesungen
getanzt und vor allem auch sehr viel
getrunken und eigentlich sollte jetzt in
diesen Minuten die Mannschaft hier an
uns vorbeifahren das ist aber leider
nicht der Fall das liegt daran dass der
Bus aufgehalten wird auf der Autobahn
umzingelt von unzähligen Fans die ganz
nah an ihren Idolen sein wollen und die
jüngste Meldung ist das wahrscheinlich
der Bus nicht mehr ganz in die
Innenstadt vorrückt weil es zu voll ist
dennoch natürlich eine Täuschung für
viele Fans aber insgesamt ist die
Stimmung hier so fröhlich so ausgelassen
das glaube ich die wenigsten argentin
der sich diesen tollen Tag für ihr Land
durch so etwas noch leben lassen also
bundesares und Argentinien feiern
gerade gesehen in Argentinien werden die
Weltmeister bejubelt aber nicht nur die
nee auch die Vize-Weltmeister in
Frankreich aber das Team tricolor das
wollte ja eigentlich nach dem verlorenen
Finale nur noch ab nach Hause doch dann
sagte Präsident macron nächster Jungs
die Menschen wollen euch danken ja und
so gab es nach den Tränen der Niederlage
in Katar den Jubel der Fans gestern
Abend in Paris
die Stadt empfängt das Team
weihnachtlich gestimmt auch wenn der
Pokal diesmal fehlt es ist ein
warmherziges heimkehrfest nach dem
verlorenen Finale vor vier Jahren wurden
sie als Weltmeister mit einer
sommerparade auf den Champs Elise
gefeiert diesmal reicht ein Hotel
balkong ich habe großartige Erinnerungen
an damals wer undenkbar gewesen heute
Abend nicht hier zu sein um Ihnen von
ganzem Herzen zu sagen
nach der Enttäuschung über den
verlorenen Titel mussten die Fans auch
noch den Nationalmannschaft zurücktritt
von Karin wenn sie mal verkraften der
die WM verletzt verpasst hatte 24
Millionen Menschen hatten das Finale von
Katar in Frankreich im Fernsehen
verfolgt
ja und gefeiert wird heute auch das
WM-Team aus Marokko Ankunft der Atlas
Löwen am späten Nachmittag in Rabat nach
der Landung ging es dann weiter zu einer
Feier in der Stadt mit vielen vielen
tausend Fans mit Platz 4 ist Marokko das
erfolgreichste afrikanische Team der WM
Turniergeschichte
Neuauflage des olympischen Tennis Finals
in Dubai gewann soeben Alexander Zverev
gegen Novak Djokovic der erste Sieg des
Hamburgers nach seiner schweren Knöchel
Verletzung
dieser Sieg überraschend souverän der
deutsche Alexander Zverev dominiert den
ersten Satz sogar gegen einen eigentlich
gut aufgelegten Novak Djokovic sei
getapeter Fuß hält der Belastung stand
und auch mental wirkt Zverev gut drauf
er holt den ersten Satz mit sechs zu
drei im zweiten Satz nimmt auf seinem
Gegner dann erneut einmal den Aufschlag
ab und gewinnt souverän mit sechs zu
vier der deutsche gewinnt das Match in
diesem showturnier und zeigt nach seiner
Verletzung gute Form für das kommende
Tennisjahr
[Applaus]
also wieder oben auf wie schön ja
Dankeschön und wir schauen noch nach
Großbritannien wo der King nach und nach
die Queen ersetzt ab Mitte 2024 sollst
Charles der dritte auch als Geldschein
in die Portemonnaies des Volk geschaffen
die Bank of England präsentierte die
neuen 5 10 20 und 50 erscheine mit der
Queen kann man aber auch weiter bezahlen
die Banknoten werden schrittweise
ausgetauscht
beim Wetter ist wieder neuer Regen teils
mit Glatteis angesagt mehr dazu gleich
von Essen Marietta Slomka begrüßte um
21:45 Uhr zum heute journal darin auch
ein Interview mit Gesundheitsminister
Lauterbach auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
einen schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter in den nächsten
Tagen kommt ein Regengebiet nach dem
anderen voran und dieses Ringgebiet das
sieht nach Osten und nach Südosten ja
und für morgen eine Tagesverlauf gibt's
trockene Abschnitte bevor dann neuer
Regen aufzieht der aktuelle Regen der
gefriert Richtung Vogtland und auch
Richtung Erzgebirge ansonsten viele
Wolken und Regen nach Norden den trocken
mit Nebel so ähnlich wie im Südosten
dort ist es aber am kältesten mit
Temperaturen von -3 bis 0 Grad
mindestens ganzem Westen bei 9 Grad
morgen am Vormittag weiterhin
gefrierender Regen dann aber Richtung
Bayern und auch Richtung Erzgebirge
ansonsten wieder viele Worte mit Regen
von Westen her da wird es allmählich
Trockner zum Nachmittag verzieht sich
der Regen weiter in den Osten dazwischen
gibt es durchaus trockene Abschnitte von
Westen her zieht dann neuer Regen auf
zum abends Temperaturen dazu höchste
Werte von 1 bis 4 Grad Richtung Bayern
und 12 Grad im Südwesten Deutschlands
die nächsten Tage werden milder es gibt
viel Regen kräftiger Wind aus Südwest
Donnerstag bis 14 Grad und Freitag sogar
bis 16 ein schöner Abend